okay
let's see if this works
hi guys i don't know if you can see it
you can see me i think it started says
it started can you guys write if you can
see me live this is my first live so we
have some technical problems
um okay say hi there david
sebastian so uh i guess
that this is working
so uh welcome everyone this is uh
my first q a live so i'm trying to
i will try in this hour maybe it might
last a little bit more to answer
your burning questions i have made sure
that
i've printed some of them because you've
asked me
a lot a lot of questions and a lot of
them are interesting so
i'm going to try to answer as many
questions as possible
now um i've seen that you have asked me
a bunch of questions in a bunch of
languages
for the sake of of simplicity let's say
let's stick to english
um i'm going to read some of the
questions in other languages and
i'm going to translate them but the next
time if this goes well
we can also do this in either in
multiple languages or we can do it in
another language it's like in italian or
in spanish or german and whatnot
so um i'm going to read the first
question from the list of questions i
have here and then you can ask me and i
can
select one of the questions there and i
see that you're writing already a bunch
of
questions i'm trying to you know to do
everything at once is a little bit
complicated but
um um let's get started and plus you're
asking in
a bunch of languages so so uh without
further ado
i wanted to read the first question by
uh jonathan quiroz
i'm sorry if i'm butchering any of your
names do you think it's possible to
achieve the c2 level in the language
without actually living in the country
where the language is spoken and so
how can i do that studying english on my
own if i have the c1 level
so as i always say what matters is not
where you live what matters is how you
live so if you live in your own country
and you have time
to um you know hang around hang out with
people that's the most important thing
apart from obviously
listening to a lot of stuff reading a
lot of stuff but i think that
in order to achieve a very very high
level you have to have
to factor in um you know people
and that means you know not just books
sometimes we think that
re reaching a c1 or c2 is just a matter
of
reading a ton of books and and doing a
lot of things watching a lot of movies
and attending like lectures to
university but the truth is
that you know personally
in the languages that i speak the best i
have spent a lot of time
with people that made a huge difference
so remember it's not where you live
it's how you live personal life i
try to have a lifestyle that allows me
to have a lot of contact with foreigners
when i start speaking language more or
less fluently i
look i seek a lot of opportunities where
i can
use the language and can have
experiences the more experiences the
better because that's
ultimately what it's all about
communicating and and living experiences
with people
across this beautiful world so
uh um
is asking a similar question like you
have suggestions for people who want to
to master uh portuguese as well this is
a complex
question i would say that um what you
should do first
is you know get a good language learning
material
so that you can get started and then you
and then you can uh
make progress i would say in your in we
have uh kevin is a colleague of mine
he's here in the chat he's moderating
the chat
and um since i unfortunately cannot do
10 things at once
he's gonna you know put uh some links um
so kevin if you're there and i think you
are you can put
add the list of resources on our
very same website lucanopul.com we have
recently created a list of resources for
a number of languages there's at least
15 languages so
actually you can go there you can click
and you can check
the resources for uh you know for
portuguese or for any other language but
i would say that in order to get started
you need to have
one good resource for your target
language that's
i would say the most important thing to
start with a good resource
resource because normally we have too
many resources and we tend to
grab this resource here this resource
there and then there are too many and we
not
we end up not doing much with any
resource that we have
so if you go to to to answer your
question
um if you look for um if you
if you click on the link uh if you go
directly to lucanopedo.com
you will see that there is a resource
section you can click there and you will
have
a lot of resources for portuguese and
the resources that are stated there for
any language
are the resources that i personally like
so let me ask a question here
so i see you guys asking questions um
someone's asked how's it going with
danish you're not the only one luca who
asked me muka j
h i'm gonna get to that i'm going to
read another question
here uh which is really interesting and
this is a very common question
how to always find time for language
learning for students actually
the question should be how to find
language time for language learning in
general it's not just for students
because
you think that you're very busy when
you're a student true
i was very busy when i was a i was
studying engineering and i was
like even going to uh to college to
channel youtube scientifically but the
truth is that life
is hectic no matter the period of your
life so
i think that one of the things that i
always
recommend my students is to plan
beforehand
meaning that if you do not plan your
time then
you're a slave to time meaning that in
my personal case what i do
for example is that every sunday and i
do it tomorrow
i'm gonna sit down for 30 minutes
doesn't take long
so for 30 minutes i'm just going to sit
down and i'm going to think
about what happened the previous week
and
i'm going to think about ways to improve
upon the way i use my time
during the previous week and that helps
me manage my time better
and the other thing is that if you're
running out of time it's because
probably you're not managing your time
correctly there is always time
to do the things that you want to do
maybe you're going to the gym you like
going to the gym
you find time for that so for language
learning if you find yourself
starting the whole day and then being
absolutely devastated and
absolutely tired sorry you're just
exhausted because
you've been you know you've been
studying the whole day
then i you should think again and you
should think
about a way to land for
me at some time of the day maybe you're
going to
um wake up a little bit earlier to
squeeze in
length turning in the morning if you can
this is what i've been doing i've been
perfecting
my uh language learning a calendar or
schedule
over the next over i would say in the
last
three years and i realized last year i'm
gonna make a video about that that
i was not finding time to learn
hungarian because i was tackling three
languages at the same time hungarian
greek and danish and then i i thought
hold the phone
wait a second there's something wrong
here and i have to manage my time
in a slightly different way and then i
found a solution so it's always a matter
of organizing your time you always have
to think
how can i organize my time better
prepare in advance
use saturday and or sunday or any day in
which you have less things to do to
carefully
think about how you use your time
because that makes a difference
i always say people ask me how do you
learn this how do you learn that
first of all before thinking about
improving your language learning
before fixing your language learning you
should fix yourself this is a big lesson
i've learned
that when i didn't find time to learn
languages just because i was not caring
on myself
my health my time uh my energy
and whatnot so
let me see one of the questions here so
i'm gonna do you know one of the
questions here one of the questions
there
uh
the truth is guys i do not use apps
i've never used babble i've never used
busu i've never used
maybe the only app i i've used but it's
really i don't use it as an app
is link i'm pretty sure that you learned
l i n g q by famed
steve kaufman who felt as a fellow i've
used that
but i'm i have never used it as an app
meaning that i do not
use this for the live me
uh when it comes to uh learning
languages
because this distracts me a lot i see it
as a sort of distraction so i tend to
use
mainly um websites
uh where i download stuff that i can
print and then i can look at why i have
for example um printed these questions
because i
like thinking on paper so um i'm
sorry to disappoint you if you're we're
looking for
the best app but i don't have an answer
because i don't use these apps
never use duolingo or busu or babel i
have made some videos with battle but
that doesn't mean that
either i use the you know the app or i
work for
or with them you're a legend bro
thanks that's that's always nice to see
see comments
um how do you demand the mom
that sounds that sounds uh that sounds
dutch
how do you maintain eating healthy when
learning a language
well that's an interesting question so
from this question you imply that maybe
it's difficult to learn languages and
maintaining
like a healthy diet is that is that your
point i'm not quite
sure but i think that the two things are
you know are quite compatible
actually i would say that the fact that
i started eating in a different way
helped me focus better so um i would say
more than maintaining
you know talk in general when you when
you are talking about
learning languages or any other
cognitive skill that you want to develop
you might want to eat better
i recently read a very interesting book
which is called brain food by i don't
remember the author she's an italian
doctor who lives in new york and she
talks about the fact that
if you eat better if you eat a brain
friendly food then you are more focused
and you can do a lot more things that
you would not
be able to do if you were eating junk
food or if
your diet was nutrition plan whatever
you want to call it
or unhealthy so um the the short answer
to that is
you should eat well first first and
foremost for your health
and then because if you eat well you
have more energy
you can do so many more things you have
more mental clarity
you can focus better so there's there's
a flurry of benefits involved with
a good nutrition plan um
so uh let's see another answer
another question from here and then um
another from you guys
i'm trying to answer as many as possible
you know
in this one hour let's let's keep it
within the one hour one hour fifteen
if you get bored you can tell me you can
tell me earlier
so uh gupp's gaps three yar
luca when you watch movies in english
are you able to understand 100
even without subtitles what are your
tips to understand movies in one's
target language
it never happened they understand 100 of
a video without subtitles because
english is a worldwide language if i
watch a video i remember that i don't
know if you guys have ever seen
i've ever watched trainspotting before
uh it's a it's a cult movie
and let me tell you the first time i
watched that movie i could not
understand a thing
i i was telling myself is this even
english and then i discovered
that you know i was kind of dismayed i
thought okay well
uh maybe maybe i don't i'm i'm speak
english well
i doubted myself because at that time i
had been learning english for
a couple years maybe three years and
then i watched the movie and i
and i and i told myself there's
something wrong here and i realized that
that was scottish
scottish english so it's totally normal
that you do not then
any person even a native speaker might
have problems
um americans i'm pretty sure they have
sometimes promised understanding british
english in some parts of england
i said even some brits have a hard time
understanding other brits
and you know not to mention scottish and
even irish
so that's that's i always if i can if
there's a possibility of using the
subtitles i use subtitles even in
english
because there's always something that
subtitles are great
visual a great fantastic tool to see
what you hear so it's something you can
resort to
if if they disturb you if you're you
know if you don't want to
launch a movie with some with subtitles
then you you
you don't need to but i think they're
here they're there to help you
and in order to you ask me how to
um what are your tips to understand
movies in one's target language well
the first thing is to watch watch movies
with subtitles
now which subtitles you're going to use
is slightly tricky depending on your
level but if you have
a level say between b1 b2 or higher
i would highly recommend you watch um
movies with subtitles
directly in the target language so
subtitles in whatever french and
you watch the movie in french with
subtitles in french
and at the beginning watching movies is
still difficult even if you have a b2
and then you watch a movie and you find
yourself
not understanding a good chunk of it it
depends on the movie
it depends on a number of factors it you
just have to
to to get to it you have to start
watching more and more and after some
time
you will start understanding more and
more you know one thing that i would say
is that you
i mean it sounds a little bit trite but
you should by all means
watch movies that you're interested in
maybe
you've already watched in other
languages you know the content
and they're cult movies and you watch
them in the target language if there's
that possibility
so that by watching more and more videos
more and more
videos on youtube uh movies this goes
for everything
then you get you start getting a better
and
better so um let me see here
um let me see let me go up because you
have a lot of questions guys it's seen
an interesting question i'm gonna try to
dig out of here but um molly fitness
uh molly i think i've seen you before
you've left a bunch of comments uh
my um my channels and thanks for being
so nice
um do you think the massive
input helps with actual speaking
abilities yes i i do
uh think that because you have to
imagine that in a language learning you
have
the main four areas like speaking
listening reading and writing
and if you think about it they
correspond to the four channels for
which we
basically acquire information we acquire
if we read through
our eyes we hear through our ears we
speak through our mouth
and we we write through our hand and
in a way they're separate so if you
think about it that's the exciting part
about language learning is that you can
you can build certain skills sub skills
separately from others if you listen a
lot if you read a lot
you never speak your speaking is going
to be non-existent or pretty poor
but these these skills are also
interconnected they're entangled so they
help each other
and when it comes to speaking massive
input helps a lot
so it seems like oh i'm just listening
so what about speaking
in order to speak and speak a language
fluently well
you have to speak you have to speak a
lot but i always
recommend that you you get a lot of
input because the base is always that
the more input you get there is no fault
in
getting massive input either in
listening and reading this is this is
very important
um so to answer a question yes i do
think the massive input helps
with speaking abilities but you have to
speak so
my suggestion would be get a lot of
input
but also plan a couple of times a week
where if you do not live in country you
get the possibility of using
your target language either with a tutor
or a tandem a friend
and someone you whom you try and you
like
so um thoughts on
uh real zero five thoughts on what you
think it's gonna take forever and how do
you overcome that
the uh the thing i always say guys is
this
do not do not focus on
the goal do not focus on the final
destination
focus on the here and now and enjoying
the process
there's a lot of writers and and you
know cognitive sciences to talk about
this the fact that if you focus on the
process if you enjoy the process
you're more likely to make it happen
every day imagine a writer who wants to
read a
write a book and he constantly says when
am i going to get finished when am i
going to get finished
you know that in the movie shrek that
the donkey goes like
are we there yet are we there yet that's
kind of
you know if you think about it it's a
matter for for impatience like are we
there yet
and a lot of people a lot of my students
and a lot of people in general ask me
all the time
um when am i going to be fluent when am
i going to get b1
b2 c1 c2 it doesn't really matter
think about that language running takes
a long time it's a long road i know it's
tried to say but i have to repeat it
it's a marathon
but since it's a marathon if you
constantly think about when it's over
it's a it's going to be a disaster try
to do a marathon and
every every half kilometer you're
constantly thinking about
when is this going to end you know
instead you should enjoy the ride
so it takes a long time you can speed up
the process always see it as a
distance you cover in a way but you have
to
if you have that mentality that it takes
it will take
time then you're gonna relax imagine
you're gonna
sail on a boat and you're moving from
say uh
gibraltar right in spain to the united
states
you know it's gonna take you a long time
so just relax on the boat and you
you just can you know enjoy enjoy the
ride or enjoy the sale whatever
enjoy the tr the the trip um
a question here uh english israel okay
the man you're
in netherlands he said that english is
weird um i don't know what that stands
for because i haven't
i don't know if you had some philosophy
position here
while i was um i was speaking
uh speaking of i think you're
you're polish did you learn latin oh yes
oh my i did
uh recently i have i don't know if you
can see it here
uh recently uh a student of mine who
happened to be a harvard a professor at
harvard of linguistics he actually
uh he teaches uh latin and he showed me
how they're teaching latin nowadays with
these amazing books and they should
do it for you know i should definitely
do it for
um for other languages where they you
have comprehensible input everything is
in latin
but it's it's illustrated and explained
in a way that it's
really easy to understand and uh my so
my answer is yes i learned latin it was
my
one maybe the favorite subject at school
uh
together with french go figure and um
i i loved it i loved it it's just that i
did it the traditional way
but i put more time and effort than
anybody else at school because i just
simply did all the things that
just a nerd or a language geek would do
so
uh but uh truth be told if i could go
back in time or
learn it in a completely different way
i've written an article about that
on my blog how to learn dead languages
because i i have students
private students on that ask me how how
do i learn
uh ancient greek how do i learn uh latin
um let me see here so uh
that's a very interesting question i
also tried my hand
at at um ancient greek
but then when i was 15 i just decided to
go for a german because it was slightly
more useful
so um adrian asks a very
is a very interesting question that i
[Music]
saw here as well and is is that possible
that you can get
a conversational level in your language
in a target language without even going
to countries in which i guess you want
to say the language is spoken at the end
the answer is yes
of course you can't with the internet
you can maybe 200 years ago
even 30 years ago uh 40 years ago
because of geopolitical
limitations you cannot even travel say
you want to learn russian was very
difficult the russians wanted to learn
english
it was a completely different world
think about the world we live in
right now um one click away you can talk
to anybody you can go to a website
and you can just hire a tutor in
whatever language it's just mind-blowing
but you can do
so if you and on top of that you can
a bunch of stuff you can beat anything a
lot of things for free you can learn the
language for free
you can get it you can create a massive
immersion
and you can speak a lot of people
without charging to the country
so that is possible so the answer is as
i said it's not where you live it's how
you live
if you spend a lot of time using the
language even if you
you know if you're just talking with
someone on skype say
okay and you maybe you don't have
anybody to talk with because you live in
a in a
in a village in australia say there's
that's no excuse because
apart from the time zone maybe but in
general there's
always um we have amazing tools and
possibilities to
to learn anything we want of course if
you move
to that country or you have a partner
speaks that language
and you live a lot of experiences there
you might acquire the language in a more
let's say native you you can reach um a
level
that would be difficult to reach just by
living in your own country but that's a
different matter of course you can speak
a language
fluently um if if if you take the time
and you have an internet connection
basically and you have the will
uh ernie says i hate subtitles that
never match what they're saying well it
depends on which
and which shows you're watching but i
would i would say if you can get good
subtitles
that match what they're saying that's
that's better because if you don't that
can get confusing
when i was watching frost do i started
watching discover that i had a
you know a channel a french channel in
my home i was so excited
i was 15 at that time that was the only
foreign channel i could watch i was just
over i was i was over the moon the
problem is that sometimes
these uh subtitles were not were not
they didn't match exactly what they were
saying but i couldn't care i
didn't care because at the end of the
day they gave me enough information for
me
uh to understand you know the sentences
so
um i was i was elated i was excited
about
about that so um let me see here
let me see does anyone else need
subtitles you're talking about subtitles
let me go down here because maybe i'm
missing some parts of the chat
oh no because you've written so many
things that now it's going down
okay while it uh let me see here it's
it's going to be difficult because now
the the entire chat is charging so while
it does
that uh let me try to see
how to go from intermediate to advanced
level in spanish i read it on the fly
before it disappeared because it's going
up
um so um well that's that's uh
that's a complex answer i would simply
say
that if you want to move from one level
to another you have to put in deliberate
practice meaning that if you get stuck
for whatever reason and you can't go to
the next level
you should change the way you're
learning so in other words if you're say
you're listening
just listening and reading and you think
that that is enough then
maybe it's time to speak um going back
to one of the questions that someone
asked about
how my danish goes i will talk about
this in
most probably in the next videos where
i'm going to talk about my updates
for 2021 and uh for
you know what my language plans um but
for danish
i would say that one thing that really
changed is that i looked back
i got stuck i started learning last year
i think it was september 2019
uh it's almost one year and a half
actually and then i
started learning with asimil then i did
pod 101 then i started
watching youtube videos and then i got
stuck
um i it's it's odd it's it's a little
bit weird for me because
i love language so much but then i just
told myself okay i have
greek and i have a hungarian i have this
and i have that and i told myself
wait a second this is too much so i
stopped
learning danish and then i said why did
i stop learning danish and the reality
was that i stopped because i was not
speaking it with anybody
so i didn't wanna i was making the same
mistake that i had made with romanian
without anybody to speak i can i was not
getting excited
and the reason why i hadn't started is
because i thought that i
i was doing 20 things at once and so i
just decided to hire a tutor and now i
started speaking danish finally
a couple of weeks ago i was three weeks
weeks ago and i got super excited so
if you want to move from a level to the
other what you need to do is you have to
get all the areas of language learning
speaking
listening writing uh what was that the
fourth one
reading listening speaking and writing
and for each area
you have to design other activities that
you haven't done before that are
slightly
more difficult than your um your current
abilities
um there is i don't know if i can i can
find it here i will
do uh you know a book tour because
everybody's been asking me about the
book tour but uh
i can't see oh i can see it now so i can
show it to you
this is one of the best books
um i don't know if kevin you can maybe
you can put the
i have also um a uh
a page also on amazon that shows all my
the books that have changed my life
if you want it kevin maybe you can
provide a
can provide a link and here in this peak
he ex this guy well there's two he
explains i
i if you guys love if you guys love
reading you should definitely read this
book
this is a book that can change your life
because it explains exactly
how you can you know be the best of the
best when
people complain that oh that guy's just
too good he's just too talented
you you should read this book that
you know dispels all the myths
surrounding the concept of talent
basically the best of the best to know
how to learn
either motor skills or language learning
or any
any other cognitive or motor skills uh
chess and talks a lot about
chess and the polgar sisters how these
little sisters became the best of the
best in in chess because
their father just put an ad asking
searching for a wife who would actually
help him raise chess champions so
you know sometimes and malcolm gladwell
as well uh byron
uh you said outliers references that
professors as well yes malcolm gladwell
if you ever heard of him
he's also a wonderful writer that talks
about
these kind of things and talks about
possibilities
talents you know the spelling a lot of
myths um
yeah kevin just uh left uh my my amazon
shop with my book recommendations there
there's a lot of books that i will talk
about because one of the things i
am passionate about is reading so um
someone rocco pagliarini i'm just
reading stuff on the go guys i'm trying
to
actually give you priority more than the
questions here even if we should do
half and half um the case
how do you learn cases there i think
there is an article on my
uh on my blog that talks about how to
learn cases and there's also audio so
you can listen to that
if you want to go deeper but basically
when it comes to learning uh not just
cases but any grammar features of
of any language you should
remember um famed hungarian polyglot
who used to say that you
learn you do not learn language from
grammar
but the other way around you learn
grammar from language
which means that and i know this sounds
a little bit trite again
you might want to get massive input as
much as you can
and while you get massive input your
brain is going to start figuring out the
patterns of course you can
also use some grammar notes that explain
and dissect some idiosyncrasies or
peculiarities of a given language that's
important
especially if your native language is
not a slavic language
but truth be told if you spend time
trying to figure out um you know cases
and
you look at tables it's so it's a waste
of time that is just going to confuse
confuse you because your brain has
two main systems let's say memory
systems
one deals well one is called deliberate
uh member you know deliberate memory
um and the other one is
another system that a procedural memory
so
basically um i'm sorry declarative
memory
and procedural memory so declarative
memory is about the things you know
and procedural memory is the things you
can do
and the problem at school is that if you
the focus is a lot on the
what we know but not on the how so you
notice that you may
know a lot of words and a lot of grammar
uh notes or grammar rules but you cannot
speak the language
so uh keep that in mind because i
kevin has provided all the details for
uh for cases there uh you know further
explanations
obviously here we're dealing with a lot
of questions but if you want to go
deeper
into this concept of learning in a
natural way be it you know russian cases
or any other
grammatical um you know peculiarity of
any other language you should definitely
learn through massive input and with a
little bit of
grammar explanations so
um iwan smith
so he's asking can you learn like so do
you have any
tips to um to learn languages
in which there are just a few just a few
resources my answer is this when you do
not have a lot of resources
you should rely on native speakers so
the human factor is always huge what do
i mean by that
let me give an example i'm well not
exactly about but i want to learn
serbian
so serbian serbo-croats but
you know this is a geopolitical
distinction but
to to for the sake of gravity and
simplicity server quote is the same
language but you have two different
versions
in server crowd i did not find resources
either in ass
you know arsenal or pod one one
resources that
they normally use so what i want to do
is i want to create my own resources so
i contacted a serbian friend of mine and
i asked
her to um i just basically wrote
my dialogues the titles in english and i
asked her to translate
these dialects for me and i'm creating
my own resources
so in other words you can
either pay someone hire someone to
create
your resources for you and i'm pretty
sure that you will find
um you know that you can find uh people
for sure that they're going to help you
and if you pay it's you know
stimulates people who it pushes people
it helps it helps
you know and i've done that for serbian
and i'm going to probably do it with
other languages truth be told
i've been learning a lot of popular
languages so i haven't had
that problem so far but i think that
if you if you find if you want to learn
a a
very exotic language or a less popular
language you should definitely
find ways to contact people to and ask
them
to create your own your personalized
learning material which is even better
than the standard one so you can use
as an example a resource that you have
asking that you've been using for other
languages or that you know that it
is good and copy the kind of style
create your own dialogues
which is or copy maybe some other
dialogues that you find somewhere else
and then you can create your own
resource i can guarantee you that this
works because i've done it before so
um let me see here we have a lot of
questions maybe you should go from the
from the from the bottom to the top um
so let me see i think
medium medium i think medium is
thanks thanks oh medium is one of the
the students we have
we have a we're running a a live program
uh for uh for students medium is one of
the students that we're having we're
having a blast
this is about the bi-directional
translation and other techniques
um mohammed i think you're not the only
one
there's a lot of people asking me are
you gonna learn arabic yes it's on the
two learn list
or to-do list but not this year probably
not the next one
and i'm still something that blocks me
as far as arabic is concerned is that i
have to learn
msa standard modern standard arabic and
then
um probably i want to learn another um
you know dialects they call it dialect
they're actually languages
that blocks me a little bit to learn two
languages for the price of one
but um because you know for those who do
not know the
the history of arabic there's the modern
standard arabic is a language that is
used in television and the media but
it's not really spoken
in the country so it's it's a little bit
like maybe not like speaking latin
but people maybe do not connect to you
as if you were speaking their own local
language and that's what excites me
that's what makes me
tick that's what makes me uh up at night
that when you speak a foreign language
you get closer to millions of people
that's that's i i know that arabic is a
is an incredible language but
i would aim for sure for a language i
can speak and
interact with and live experiences with
with foreigners
with uh you know so it's it's important
for me
and that blocked me a little bit but i'm
gonna get to it because arabic is a
fantastic language
and and uh hebrew uh
yet yeah hebrew i have it i have
turkish then i have what is the most
efficient way to improve here for living
with native speakers that's an
interesting question arabic
and i have hebrew and i'm going to learn
all of them so i got asimil
and i'm going to make it happen so um
i am trying to keep up with the
questions mikhail greben check
i might learn check as well but to learn
czech before i want to
i want to improve my polish and then
serbian and then i will most probably
learn czech
one of the reasons why i haven't learned
track is because if you want to learn
a language that belongs to the same
family you should be cautious because if
you
mask if you're trying to learn too many
languages are similar
and you haven't acquired a very high
level in one of the languages you might
end up mixing them
so uh idiomas
i don't think the finish is on my list
but you never know i have my fellow
polyglots
stefano i don't know if you guys know uh
stefano lingue paciones youtube channel
for those who do not know he's one of
the best italian polyglots
and you should definitely check his
youtube channel maybe kevin you can you
can add it there
so check him he speaks amazing finish
and
a wide arrange range of languages we
made a a multilingual video together
on this very same channel and what about
armenia and reading is another
incredible language that i would like to
learn um
so guys we're going too fast
so what's how's it going with the
pronunciation it's tough
and when it's danish and i spoke danish
three times with my
with my tour um it most most of the time
swedish comes out but this is normal
because
i just started speaking so um swedish is
um you know my dominant language
scandinavian language so he gets in the
way
talks to me say hey what are you doing
what is that weird language you're
getting
out of your mouth is that danish no no i
that's i am i am
here no it takes taking some space
swedish is taking some space
yes kevin he just wrote stefano oswego
that's that's his name
um how do you plan your language
learning how do you structure
asks oh that's that's uh that's a big
one i for all
you know we're going to collect all
these questions uh which
i don't know if there's a way guys
because this is the first time i do it
to save the chat
to save this chat but we are going to
take into account all the questions that
i could not answer because
because it's impossible to answer all
the questions right now
and and we're going to try to tackle um
you know most of them with time
so uh christian saludo
how do you what do you do not to forget
the languages that you do not use or do
you use less
well i i tend to get a little bit rusty
uh but i have a lifestyle that allows me
to
uh fortunately to use a let's say
between four and eight languages it's on
the to-do list to make a video about
that to show you how i actually live and
how what what allows me to speak
between four a minimum of four every day
to a maximum of ten
but i never speak 14 languages every day
it never happens
that i'm able to speak 14 all the 14
languages
and the more languages i learned the
more difficult it's going to be remember
i watched a video by professor
wellies i don't know if you guys know
professor welles he's a famous bollywood
and i remember that he was like he's he
there was
babel no more that's a book about
polyglots and the author interviews
professor well he's asking him
how he deals with language and he goes
like i do
latin for 15 minutes and then um ancient
greek for 15 minutes and then i do
chinese for 50 minutes i i i i was
extremely impressed by that video and
i'm extremely impressed by his
discipline
but it's not really realistic for the
average joe and it's not even realistic
for me
who uh i'm a language buff without a
doubt
i would i spend a lot of time in
language learning
but i am not you know you see me
now and you see me through youtube so
you you see me as
a language learner but you do not know
what i do in my day-to-day
um you know activities for example i i
there's a lot of other things i do and i
like and language learning is
is an important part of my life i would
say that i dare say that
you know my life hinges on language
learning because i work with languages
and because i use languages all the time
but i am not obsessed by them i know
that it sounds weird i was obsessed at
the beginning when i
when i started my youtube channel that
sparker sparked my interest again for
language learning and i was
trying to do this and right do not do
that guys do not try to
learn as many languages as you can
because you want to the number
numbers don't matter what matters is how
you're using the languages and you have
to ask yourself
how is this language making a difference
in my life that is the kind of question
you want to ask yourself
um so uh let me see
i'm almost b2 in hungarian you think i
can start chinese now from scratch
if my goal is to reach c1 in both of
them by the way in polish i can have
conversation practice
with you for free thanks um
you can start chinese from scratch uh if
you i don't see any reason why if you're
learning hungarian you should not
start learning chinese these languages
are completely different the only
question you have to ask yourself is
do you have time to tackle both
languages if you're gonna start learning
chinese make sure that you keep um
keep hammering on on hungarian that's
the trick
that's the difficult part because we
tend to say okay i'm gonna do that i'm
gonna tackle another language but
especially if you want to move from
b2 to c1 that is going to entail a lot
of
of of activities for hungarian and then
on top of that
you're going to have to learn chinese as
well so my answer is of course you can
do that
if you have the drive the will the time
and the circumstances that are right
so you can do that nicolas
i am in this i am in rome this is my
apartment and i'm gonna
i'm gonna go to poland as usual um
at the beginning of may and then i'm
gonna probably stay in poland for three
months which is my favorite country in
europe right now
so um let me see here
uh derek clock what strategies for
working with
tutors for speaking practice i couldn't
read the rest because
you know it was it was buried by the the
other questions
so
this also takes some time to reply and
we don't have that time but i think we
have
one uh i think we have one um
uh one nice um you know
piece on our blog i think kevin is like
how to work with your tutors if not even
two
and we even have a couple of youtube
videos but to sum it up to be to be
you know to go straight to the point i
would say that one thing that you do not
want to do
so let's start with the things you do
not want to you do not you should not do
is just to walk in a conversation with
your tutor without knowing what to do
so let them lead in a way you want to
lead yourself we come from years and
years where the teacher is that the
center
as it's like a solar system where the
the sun is at the center and we or
and the planets orbit around the sun in
our new system
we your your tutor and you you're like
two
planets or maybe two stars orbiting
around each other so this the center of
gravity the center of cognitive gravity
i would call it
is in the middle you should take
initiative and you should come up with
things you want to do so it should be
conversations about
stuff you like i always prepare things
beforehand with my
two wonderful hungarian teachers greek
tutor
and danish tutor i always prepare my
lessons beforehand
i always choose what i want to talk
about and i always take 20 minutes
before the lesson
to prepare a few notes about a few
sentences or a few words that i want to
use that i do not know
so that i can facilitate the
conversation because
if i tackle a topic that i love but i
don't know much about or
that i know a lot about but not in my
target language then i'm going to
struggle too much
so you want to find yourself first you
want to prepare the lesson
lead ask your tutor to you know
to give you the possibility of choosing
if you find a tutor who tells you
and this guys has happened a lot of
times with my students they go like
i've i have a tutor but my tutor
wants to spend all the time reading
grammar reading like a book and telling
me what
how the grammar works do not for the
life of you accept something like that
because grammar you can read by yourself
so with your tutor you should just do
stuff that is speak
that is about speaking you know um so
kevin
i think kevin is the author of that um
on on the blog um
so let me see um
so someone someone was married there um
how many hours were you spending
learning russian i
um it's also in one of the questions
here um i learned russian basically
um starting with arsenal in
2004 and i almost gave up
and someone asked me here i don't
remember where it is
but someone asked me uh about um you
know what should i do when it comes to
using a keyboard so i almost gave up
when you when you're
how to use a keyboard when you're
learning a language with a non-latin
script
and this reminds me of russian of what
happened in russian
2004 i almost gave up because i was
painstakingly
typing each letter because i hadn't
downloaded
um a keyboard a russian keyboard and
my advice is first to answer this other
person's question
is my advice is to guys don't load a
keyboard phonetic keyboard so that you
can type from the very beginning and
start typing start forming sentences
that you like
because that helps you it's it's maybe
you can even
retype some sentences that you see on a
language learning material because this
helps you
figure out how the language works and
it's fun it's not you don't have to
write anything by hand you can start
typing directly in the target language
and maybe if you want to hand write hand
writing is
it's a different ball game it's a
different matter but you can start by
typing
so and as far as russian is concerned i
almost gave up
in 2004 because i i had to just insert
every single letter
i come to think of it like in hindsight
i was i was
that was bad anyway so uh and then and
then i started um
in 2008 i made this uh russian video i
mean i
i could i met some people i spoke some
russian
over those the span of the four years
four years then in 2008 when i made this
russian video my russian was okay but
the fact that i was making
youtube videos and i got a lot of
attention so i started um started
reading
again and starting uh speaking with amir
amir uh
there's another uh russian polygamy he
also was on television we were having
fun
having conversations with skype he was
teaching me slang and stuff and then i
went to russia
for a conference in 2000 um 2013
and i met my ex-girlfriend and
i uh i was with her for three years
and i started speaking russian every day
i went to russia multiple times
and um having being in a relationship
made a huge difference obviously because
i started not only
was i speaking more russian but the fact
that i was
with a russian girl and the fact that i
was visiting
the country that i had been in the
country obviously
made me want to learn even more so i
started listening to echo muscle for
example which is a radio
a radio i don't know if you ever heard
of that and then
um yeah kevin is just posting luca
speaking russian 2008
then i was i have a video where the
organizers of the conference you know
invited me i arrived i landed in i think
you should imagine
it's the airport of of moscow
and the whole story unfolds from there
have you written a book yes i have
i have written a book and it should be
somewhere here
i don't know where it is but it's hidden
here but it's in polish so we've written
a book
but we uh are in the process of uh
getting a book out i don't want to make
any promises guys i don't know when this
is coming out but
we're working on it okay so uh after
after
a few years i can tell that finally uh
we have the intention of getting this
out as soon as possible because uh a lot
of people are asking me about this
um uh let me go up because someone asked
a very interesting question lino's three
six
eight three hundred six do you recommend
using
mnemonics to learn thousands of kanji
like the high six stores
it depends it depends uh
ask yourself this what is it that you
want to do with japanese do you want to
speak it
do you want to read it do you want to be
able to recognize
a text because most often than not more
often than not what happened is that
people wanting to learn japanese or even
chinese but this is particularly uh the
case
for japanese they ask how many countries
do you know how many characters do you
know
does it really matter you should ask
yourself how many words do you know
because kanji makeup works and if you
want to learn
how to write kanjus well then you can
use
mnemonics and mnemonics are good but for
speaking the language
understanding texts memorizing how words
are said
or even typed you don't need any of that
so
yeah if you want to use memory
techniques
by all means they do work and they're
beautiful luca thomas
i don't know kevin if if you can provide
you know a link luka toma is a friend of
mine
he is a language he's one of the best
japanese
tutors i think in the world and he is
you know he's shown me
also his website you can see how he
creates stories how he
designs um things so that you can
remember the characters and it's
beautiful how he does it but
again if you want to memorize kanjis
that's
that's great if you have to pass an exam
etc but remember that speaking
learning to to speak a language to speak
japanese in this case and being able to
read text or typing even typing in
japanese
you know you don't need to be able to
write you know spend
a lot of time on these stories if you
want to and that's your priority by all
means go
uh go for it but it's i i don't find a
strictly necessary
um i remember i met a japanese girl that
was like four or five years ago and
i remember we were in a we were in a bar
uh grammy a couple of drinks and then we
were joking and she was
you know i asked her something she could
not remember a japan native japanese
you could not remember how to hand write
because we were handwriting stuff
a lot of japanese and and even chinese i
think they cannot remember
how to write because they don't use it
anymore they type most of the time
so uh
so i guess a funny comment so
let me see could you talk about
translation strategies
what is the most efficient way to
improve if you're living with a native
speaker how to avoid talking in english
to have more conversations in the target
language
well you have to have a plan this is
this has been happening a lot with me
that i've been living a lot with
foreigners and i
i tend to tell them immediately that i
want to speak their languages and
and then if they don't and most of the
time it happens uh
unfortunately that people resort to
english if you have
for example there was here i had um a
girl from kazakhstan living here
she spoke french and russian and then i
had a french guy
so with a french guy when i was with the
french guy i was used to speak french
but with her
russian not all the time sometimes
english the problem was when they were
together it was difficult to speak
russian or
you know it would have been difficult if
she didn't know french because she knew
french to speak french
so in but in general if you want to
speak the the targeting language you
should gently
ask them the best is just ask them hey
can i speak the language for five
minutes
for 10 minutes maybe in specific
situations when they're cooked when you
find yourself in
in in the kitchen and you'll talk i
don't know you talk to this girl or to
this guy you live with
and you can start with bits and pieces
of of
you know like a five minute session
because if you start imposing the
language especially if you started
speaking
if you started your relationship with
this person um the moment they arrived
you arrived the moment you started
living together and
you started in language say english most
of the time
then it's going to be difficult it's
going to be unnatural to
switch to another language and impose
that language upon these people so you
have to take it step by step
small habits tiny habits you know that
you can introduce
there's a beautiful book that talks
about that it's called elastic habits
and you want to take a look at that it's
just if you want to get into different
habits start very like
tiny tiny micro habits that you can
start with and then
with time you can expand upon it
so let's see here uh let me see
what is the most efficient way to learn
from asumu i have an entire course some
italian that
it's too long to explain but basically
use a strategy that is called a
bi-directional translation where i
translate first in my
uh native language and then back i mean
the
the text of asimo and i have this is
done
with a specific strategy according to a
specific um
you know timing uh
the timing is really important it's not
just the what and the how but also the
when
and uh unfortunately i cannot go deeper
because it will take us an hour
and uh we have a lot of questions um
nathan luca how how does your family
close social circle react to your
language buffery what are
wait i lost you there i was reading this
but then i lost it
uh i don't know uh let me see if i can
i can find it again nope sorry i lost it
um
they react quite well in the sense that
um they appreciate what i do
especially my parents when they were
alive at the beginning my father did not
understand
my choice of pursuing languages meaning
okay
i had gotten a degree in engineering and
he had
um strongly let's say recommended me
take that that i take that direction
which i did and i don't regret anything
because i
really loved mathematics and physics and
i am very passionate about especially
physics and i have a lot of
i don't know maybe you cannot see it i
don't know if you ever heard of
this book which is douglas adams the
hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy
so there's a lot of books about you know
einstein and stuff i love this stuff but
um but my father was disappointed at the
beginning but then he was very
very happy that um he realized that this
is what
makes me tick and uh i think that's the
most important thing and
generally my sister my twin sister sees
me as a little bit of a freak
but in a good way you know so um
they're all proud so that's that's um i
think
that's the most important thing they
react well um
the people who know me they know my
passion so they they
react well and the thing that makes me
proud is that when people live
together with me um in the apartment
they a lot of them they started learning
new languages because they got inspired
by the way you live
so living with me has inspired them to
learn other languages which is probably
the best compliment i can get
um mohammed i think you're asking a
question about arabic now you're asking
is speaking to yourself a good training
to achieve fluency
yes it is but you have to know how to do
it if you know how to do it properly and
you just don't randomly talk to yourself
that's it's an amazing tool
that can skyrocket your language skills
um
and maybe one day i'll i'll make a video
about that
i'm i'm training my students i'll train
uh you know just
in this live program that we're doing
right now i i will show them exactly how
to do that
um but yes there are ways that you can
you can use uh you can you can design
there's a plan you can design to
start talking to yourself and it makes a
difference
in my case it's making a huge difference
especially i've been using this with
greek now i'm using this with hungarian
and i'm
most probably going to be using this for
danish
then vichaan this is a sweet
encouragement from family is one of the
best forms of motivation
yes sometimes i've heard it from a lot
of americans not so much in europe i
don't know guys
from the other side of the pond if this
is true a lot of americans told me that
they feel like they're a little bit like
misfits in a way because they the the
other people in their like social circle
let's say family members or
uh or simply friends they do not
understand their passion for languages
so they they
they think they're kind of geeks or
weird weirders or something
but um you know
i think that sometimes it's ignorant
even if it comes from your family it
doesn't matter if they don't know
if i don't understand your passion it's
not the end of the world you know the
most important thing is that you believe
in yourself because your mindset is
what makes a difference and don't let
other people's voices
drown your own inner voice
you know this this is a a big lesson
from steve jobs
that one of in one passage he talks
about this is a very
it's a very beautiful passage and i
think that at the end of the day you can
listen to other people's
uh advice or other people's opinions or
other people's comments
but at the end of the day you have to
listen to your heart that's the only
the only voice that really tells the
truth is the voice that resonates in
your mind in your heart
um
greetings from turkey hi are you still
planning to learn turkish yes i
am i show the i show the you know the
the turk the luchak san jose it's in
french
but yes it's one of the languages i want
to learn definitely
um andre does it pay to use a book for
mastering sentences structures such as
glossika
i've never used glossika so i do not
know but
uh using some some let me show you here
if i can find it
yes so using some books i have my
my my library here so it's easy to find
so
this is japanese sentence banners for
effective communication
this is um one of the best resources you
can find for japanese
because it helps you build sentences
uh in it this is not this is not a
travel guide this is not just that oh
how's it going or can i order this or
can i order that it explains the
mechanics and dynamics of forming
sentences in a language
like japanese and it's one of my
favorite books
it's called japanese sentence patterns
for effective communication and it's
beautiful because
it it talks a little bit of a grant
about grammar but it mainly focuses on
communication and that's the most
important thing
um so keep that in mind if you're
learning japanese but if you find books
that talk about how to build
sentences more than giving you stock
sentences you can use
in certain situations situations or
circumstances
then i think uh you should you should go
for the one that focuses on
communication
okay i don't know if this is still
working
i hope so which city do you live in i
live
in rome if you can hear it because it's
uh it interrupted
uh the communication i think now is
thank you andrew says thank you most
welcome
so you guys are going very fast let me
try to tackle this
let me see if this works um
so let me go back to some of the
questions here because i don't
ignore all the nice people who wrote
this these questions does steven
questions input hypothesis
imply we can become fluent in speaking
slush writing by exclusively
listening and reading no you can't get
fluent in language
playlists and reading for the reasons i
stated before you can
you have four separate skills you can
you know
you listen about and you read a lot that
helps
in the process of speaking but um truth
be told you have in order to speak you
have to speak a lot
and listening reading helps so when
someone says oh i can just speak my way
to fluency
it's not true it actually slows you down
because if you're just focusing on
conversations maybe with tutors you're
spending
uh time and energy that's fine but
you know i think that one of the the
greatest advantages of this of this time
is the fact that we can get massive
input and we can
craft our own way and our own material
that we can
consume gladly consume
in our daily life and we can do it
everywhere so i would say
no if you want to speak you have to
speak but you you can
do both you can get massive input and at
the same time you can have a plan to
to speak the language with tutors or or
whatever
seek whatever possibilities you can find
to
practice the language so um
let me see here some other questions um
i can go down so
this is an interesting question uh what
is your opinion let me see how
i lost it on geeking i don't know there
was something of pronunciation
well i i couldn't i couldn't see the the
end the rest of the question but
basically you were asking what's your
opinion about those who are
obsessed by uh maybe not obsessed but
you spend a lot of time
figuring out how to pronounce the
language well or maybe they
just care about pronunciation i would
say if you start
caring about pronunciation honing your
pronunciation
or focusing on the phonetic manners of a
language from the very beginning from
the get-go it's a good choice
because it's we're very good at learning
but
as human beings we're not very good at
unlearning things
so if you learn a language to fluency
and you speak it with a very heavy
accent then
undoing or unlearning untying the knot
or unlearning phonetic patterns is going
to be quite difficult and there's always
some merit to wanting to spend some time
um you know honing your
your pronunciation or your intonation
pronunciation your
your phonetic patterns whatever you want
to call it
uh but this should not go to the
detriment of actually learning the
language you can do both at the same
time it's not that
this comes you know a story comes to
mind i have a very nice
student of mine who'd been learning
chinese and he's from germany and
he's been learning sometime you know for
for a few months with me
so both serbian and chinese i also coach
people in languages i do not speak
that's about that's coaching not
teaching by the way
and one day after i've i think i hadn't
spoken with him for a month and then
i talked to him in one of our coaching
sessions and he goes like
um i stopped learning chinese and i go
like
what happened and he said oh i found
this amazing
um pronunciation course and but then
it turned out to be an obsession so he
started being so obsessed with
with pronouncing the chinese characters
or the chinese words chinese in general
well they completely forgot about
learning the language that does not have
to happen i told them
stop here there there and then you have
to go back
on track and remember that pronunciation
is an integral very important part of
the language but
learning it is has to be something that
you do on top of doing everything else
it doesn't have to become an obsession
because if that happens
then um you know that's that's not
that's not good
um what is the best word method to learn
from it is okay somebody asked yes let
me see here do you think hebrew is
useful to learn than
far for c nowadays i have i gotta
confess that i
am not sure if hebrew is gonna help you
with farsi
i suspect that it might not be the case
but i gotta confess that i do not know
because i don't speak i know that hebrew
is a semitic language
and farsi is a language on its own you
know so
um i i cannot really answer this
question to tell you the truth
um how come nobody ever learns hindi
christopher i have three
three students who are actually learning
hindi there's a lot of people maybe you
don't know a lot of people
learning hindi um
so let me see here what is your opinion
and geek out on phonetics to sound
better that was the question that i saw
now um so
how much does ap ipa look oh
this that was an interesting one i can't
see it anymore
because there's something with this chat
so
i take a look at something and then it
goes up um
i've always wondered if anki is better
than an actual notebook i use notebooks
to learn
words i have a technique to use
notebooks i don't use anki at all
a lot of my students do not like anki
some others do so
i i think if you want to use it and you
like it by all means go
go buy i've never used it so i can't
really tell
but you know if you want to commit words
to your long-term memory you have
you have to use a system you have to
repeat somehow with anki or without
um so let me see here
um ice hi there luke have been no this
is do you prefer learning a language in
depth for a couple of years or do you
learn some languages just to a basic
level
speak languages and travel the world
beautiful that's that's a beautiful type
a
beautiful name you have there i do not
dabble in languages if i start learning
a language i want to learn it to fluency
because
the moment when a language becomes
exciting for me really exciting
is when actually i can i can start using
it with people
so if i embark upon the beautiful quest
of learning a language i do it
with the idea in mind that i'm going to
be learning it for a long long time
so what's your opinion on fluent forever
i saw that question before it
disappeared from my eyes i have it
i have it somewhere uh here i think it's
a great book
um i i've even personally interacted
with this author
um gabriel gabriel of gabriel never know
how to pronounce gabriel gabriel anyway
he's a great guy i think the book is
great the last part is not for me
meaning that he
learns through flashcards which i do not
use so
i didn't really you know i i
i was not particularly excited about the
second part of the book but
whatever you know he he basically lays
out the
the theoretical framework and then he
talks about specifically how he does
things
um with flashcards i do not use that
method i've never used
flashcards but i think that what he says
in the the first part of the book
laying out all the you know the various
techniques and principles is spot on
so uh what else here um
okay i'm trying to to stabilize the chat
[Music]
wait a second let me see if this works
okay
i do have a heavy accent in german on my
higher level how can i improve my accent
i said but before that
not to sound discouraging but if if you
have
a heavy accent if you've been speaking
the language at the c1 level
it's going to be difficult to undo
unlearn the the way you speak to speak
in a different way because every time
that you speak
your your brain goes into automatic mode
there's a part of your brain that has to
do with habits
so when you form sentences your brain
resorts to
a certain kind of circuitry that has to
do with uh
basically speaking um you know
uh speaking automatically and when you
speak automatically
you've noticed this in your own native
language one word follows the other
one word leads to the other and your
phonetic
patterns you follow certain automatic
phonetic patterns and it's
going to be really difficult to undo
them so i don't know if the game is
worth the candle
in this regard let me go back to a
couple of other questions here
that i wanted to um to address
we're getting to one hour uh and 15
minutes let's keep it to one hour and
30 minutes and then even if i love
you're asking
so many interesting questions and i got
so excited i could talk for the next
five hours and
tell you the truth but i have to call it
quit sooner or later
um what is the best way to learn a
foreign language through music and games
i would just say that um if
if you choose games that you like
and you choose music that you like well
then that's
only a good step a good beginning a good
start is half to battle that day and the
second thing is that you should
aim at comprehensible input so in the
case of songs
what i would say is listen to your
favorite song
choose music you like then go to just
the title of the song
lyrics and prints or just
take a look at the text of the song so
that you can actually see it
learn it understand what it says and
then you can keep playing and maybe keep
even keep singing for for games maybe
you can play this the the game
in the language you know well and then
you can play it again in a language that
you know less well
if you know the language at a higher
level you can use it directly in the
target language
i think i remember that it started
before i stopped
using um playing games because playing
games was one of my biggest passions
then i realized that was sucking a huge
amount of time
i remember that um i spent it was a
record
i think i spent like almost 24 hours uh
just playing games because
i had my tonses removed that happened i
don't know 10 years ago
and and and my um it was so painful
you know to swallow anything that in
order to
forget about the world i started playing
like 24 hours
and that was the moment i realized that
you know that was a little bit too much
but if you like games and if you
spend a reasonable amount of time with
games that's a great
great resource that you can use to you
know to kill
the proverbial two words with one stone
on the one hand you're
you're playing a game you like and on
the other hand um you're learning
languages you know
um advice to learn hungarian for
uh for beginners i would start with
assimil for hungarian it's great it's a
little bit outdated it's a little bit
old
i don't know if i can i
don't see it here i don't know where it
is but
um i would start with hungarian there's
also petra he's she's my personal
teacher
she has um an amazing um an amazing
website i'm using
um everything that she produces i even
subscribe to her patreon
because she's just great so apart from
the fact that she's a wonderful teacher
she's producing a lot of
input for beginners for intermediates i
just love i watch
all her videos every day i watch a
two-minute video that she maybe i can
write
here let me see if i can find it's
called easy hungarian
which not to be confused with with the
channel so this is her channel
maybe you can write it on it's just
hungary.com
so um that's that's what i i didn't know
about her when i started learning
hungarian but definitely if you
if you're starting from scratch i would
get asmu but
i would definitely use this i just wrote
it there i don't know if you can see it
so um
let me ask let me address a couple of
other questions here do you keep a word
list
how often do you repeat them i do not
keep wordless i don't like word lists
but
i jot down things on my uh notebooks i
can show you
uh maybe give me a second because it's
it's just
on the other side so
here so basically
i use these notebooks here to
you know basically what i do now i can't
go into detail but basically i
do i have a specific technique where i
jot down fragments not not words so do
not commit the
the the sin of jotting down single words
i always write fragments i take them
from different sources and then
i link them together so that i can form
stories or conversations that are
meaningful for me and i remember pretty
much everything that is in that book
there's a lot of details
it would take me an hour to explain this
uh but um
that's to answer your question i do not
keep word lists but i
create my own um let's say
uh lists of fragments that i use
to convey meaning within
meaningful uh meaningful topics or
topics that are meaningful to me
um kevin says time check we are at one
hour 15 minute mark
uh you're right so i will speak for five
more minutes
and then we're going to end this i like
this
and if you like it here we have hundreds
and hundreds of questions
so um so unfortunately we
we we ca we could not address all of
them
so uh hard to think in a target language
i have a
i have a youtube channel a youtube video
that talks about that you can write how
to think in a target language
um have you ever read alice in
wonderland in different languages that
translate yes so you have i have
alice in wonderland somewhere here in
multiple languages and i also have
harry potter i tell you truth i've just
read the first book by harry potter but
i have it in multiple languages and
obviously
uh the little prince i have it in
chinese russian and hungarian and all
the other languages
and uh and i also have it you know you
can see
it's in hungarian i have it in this is
it's in
in russian so for example i read it in
multiple languages
it is one of my favorite books okay
so um guys you're
you're you're you're asking so many
interesting questions it's just amazing
i would i would be spending like it's
it's really exciting this is really
exciting
um so um this is it for now
uh as i said we are trying to you know
keep it
within the one hour and 15 minutes
although truth be told that would go on
for hours
and i hope you like this work this is
just a test to see how this goes and if
you like it
we might make other other ones we have
for this year a lot of surprises we're
working on a lot of stuff
so i'm pretty glad of how things are
going and i thought that i would like to
have more contact with you you know just
like
not just putting youtube videos up there
and just hey guys take a look and that's
it you know
having uh more um content and maybe even
show
sometimes like some live sessions on um
you know how to uh basically how to do
things
like how to do things in practice anyway
um
so guys it's been uh yeah someone says
no
jaffinito's like already ended yes it's
just because we told
my team and i we said okay we're gonna
keep it within the one hour and a half
because they tend to ramble
a little bit as you've noticed
especially when you're asking interest
so many interesting
questions and i have here you know from
from facebook from instagram from from
youtube i have
hundreds and hundreds of questions and
and we will we will
we will take uh you know keep asking
questions because we are
you know we've liked these questions and
and we uh we're saving uh each and every
one
of them and then we we're going to try
to give as many answers as possible
guys been fantastic thanks a bunch uh
you're the best and uh i'll i'll talk to
you without you very soon
bye bye wherever you are in the world
and happy language learning